we put the casts on blast man as we go
through the latest castings of all your
favorite movies today on fat man on
Batman today we're gonna talk about some
famous people got put in some famous
movies gonna make some famous money and
we get to watch yeah couples that we are
will ensure it's a dirty focused Tony
Stark movie - what do we got mark bring
us through the casting we got the big
one the big one if it's a big one if
it's if this is the red fox give them a
give them a single
in the spider-man homecoming picture
yes which we're all eagerly anticipating
anticipating already I've already set
aside money for it have you yeah is
there a special fund for movies you want
to see homecoming fund coming for
homecoming definitely it's got some
money and jizz in the jar we knew that
the actress performer zendaya was going
to be in spider-man I'm coming me being
a middle-aged man tell me who that is
me being also middle-aged man know that
she's on a bunch of like or had been on
a bunch of Disney Channel kind of things
welcome to I only know this looks more
than Kevin according to the internet
told me that she's gonna track this
neither of us are from she's she's way
young if we don't know her absolutely
all right so she was on kid shows and
now she's getting big she sings is well
she like she dances was that girl lick
the doughnuts is she like ariana grande
Grande's like I've done a lot of things
like billboard top ten hits I licked a
doughnut once get off my dick about it
suddenly the headlines are ariana grande
as a dick dickie Grande where's
doughnuts on it
she was also good on SNL there he goes
big compliment really good so much so
that I'm like look all doughnuts you
want your [ __ ] funny also I like
doughnuts funny goes along with me
and doughnuts go a long way of bullets
so if you want bored with you but she's
not in this movie stop talking about her
so who sews and guesses she's been cast
as Mary Jane Kerr Jim Watson let me take
a guess
Martin yes the whole of the internet
joined and sang kumbaya was like what a
good decision well here's the here's the
weird things and ayah from what I can
tell is that the very list of mixed race
I'm pretty sure she's black maybe black
had something else she is not like she
is not a redhead okay I expected knowing
the Internet as I do when race ever
comes into conflict in any way you're
mad yes with comic book characters of
sort of the venerable institution
there's no race trading betrayers I was
I was like buckling in I was getting the
popcorn waiting for the unit to lose its
[ __ ] mind it kind of did it didn't I
didn't hear anything no exact I saw a
piece with like Stan Lee weighs in on
zendaya casting and you know predictably
it wasn't like he's like he was like
who's a day predictably sounds like
great that's fantastic awesome but I
didn't think that it was alike well we
better check in with Stan Lee because
everyone's mad I didn't hear anyone
being met no no there are lots of people
girding for like the oncoming storm that
never arrived
like the first hurricane in the cycle of
hurricanes before like oh [ __ ] is ruined
the East Coast they said a light dusting
yeah it fell apart before it's yeah
before it hit landfall or whatever lands
that was Coleco made landfall
welcome to weather info like that would
make me the other guy well let's go
thank you
oh yes Willard and [ __ ] al together
again
alright so zendaya gets cast is Mary
Jane people are indifferent or at least
not angry not I mean
is anyone happy other people like him
away there was this great video that
floated around with Tom Holland in
zendaya zendaya zendaya you say is a day
i season die you say tomato I say tomato
- yeah somebody semangat tonight oh
thank [ __ ] no we spent a lot of money on
this we're not going [ __ ] put a flirt on
the Internet of the two of them and some
other bloke dancing and it's the most
adorable thing you've ever seen it's
like that is my Peter Parker's mom is
that in the movie no it's just like this
them dancing and realize like Facebook
live or whatever in their hotel room cuz
you know it's called homecoming so there
better be some [ __ ] Honka I can't
tell you I look forward to this movie in
such a big bad way maybe more than any
Marvel movie prior to this because this
movie has the promise of a John Hughes
movie to it as well as the super heroics
of a Marvel movie with one of the care
of the planet's most popular characters
after Batman spider-man this I'm so
ready for this there's other spider-man
movies I'll be honest that was kind of
indifferent about even when they were
coming and stuff this one I'm very
excited about because I loved that Civil
War depiction spider-man this kid keeps
talking Queens the whole time I'm in oh
I'm in already but [ __ ] I'm bringing
everybody I mean it's one of those
things where it like and I love
spider-man to say maybe second
spider-man video that's good don't
acquire just too old for fun right like
my voice is the first time we're gonna
see spider-man the way it should be
seeing a kid in high school that's when
he got his powers and [ __ ] and they did
it in high school with [ __ ] Toby but
he looked like a high school teacher
like he looked like you should be
biology and I'm emo yeah
he's dancin Pete Parker all right so we
all love this idea
look I just want to see the movie I
don't give a [ __ ] Cass Bernard honest as
[ __ ] Mary Jane Watson wig or not and
I'd still be on board for this right you
know what I've actually want to see that
Barrymore zendaya is gonna happen and
we're gonna all love it like [ __ ]
again I don't care who plays this part I
just want to see this movie so bad
spider-man in high school going to a
dance with the vulture swinging in and
[ __ ] beating up high school kids
that's my kind of movie with Tony
Stark's still making a mac on his head
yes I don't even think about that we're
getting the [ __ ] backdoor Iron Man
sequel which sounds dirtier than I meant
it but oh my god I can't wait for this
movie okay next up big casting news oh I
like this it's not confirmed yet no this
is a good story
well there's in tops being considered
give me a single for this big news
there's a big news they're making a
young Han Solo film are they yeah so
they tell me
Miller the Lord the fellas behind the
lego picture and that's been on our
excellent movies have cast a fella named
Eldon Allen white who I feel like I need
to say like I'm in the boys of Brazil
and they are now circling somebody to
play young Lando Calrissian okay go to
shot who is that mark barnard in' back
to the one donald glover that makes
sense doesn't it though let me go back
to cheetah that makes so much sense
remember one point like he wanted to be
spider-man
yeah and for some reason they were like
well that just couldn't happen ever now
they're like hey man [ __ ] you may not
be spider-man but how would you like to
be another pop-culture icon Lando
Calrissian before he brings in the
Empire and sells that insult they may
show when they played a card game and
win the Falcon you know what I'm saying
this may be a pre Cape Lando Calrissian
or a different color cape
yeah gold gold cape they might talk
about the best been being built
you notice that like it's not ready at
Cloud City right in the way that all
these movies seem to have to presage
nothing we know sewer you know
boy I was gonna been here quicker but
they're building this Cloud City thing
there it is let's see the clouds
take that Lucasfilm will give it to you
for free just gonna give us tickets the
premier power is what is his rapper name
oh [ __ ] god this Gambino there it is
there I'm [ __ ] hip kids not not your
granddaddy you don't [ __ ] even know
Kurtis Blow Lando Calrissian I hope it
happens it's so [ __ ] smart
he's got charm he can be funny as [ __ ]
in these Dee's actually very handsome
despite the fact that he plays funny so
much I've never seen him be I mean it's
almost the any Murphy going from trading
places like boomer ooh I was a sexy
Eddie Murphy actually [ __ ] boomerang
any Murphy's not [ __ ] around
yesterday a girl remember Chris Rock
sanity is like first the Fat Boys break
up now this very on the Chris Rock at
that point dog lover lando calrissian
gets our two very enthusiastic trademark
infringement thumbs up next up in
casting news they're making a sequel to
Blade Runner blade runner's happenin
again kids and I guess Harrison Ford
it's character Deckard yes is clearly
not a replicant because he's older yeah
so but I guess they can include it yeah
you know what maybe he's a different
generation of it they can include a
young version that comes out with that
[ __ ] face painting [ __ ] they did
Robert Downey jr. CG in Civil War I like
that move that's dope not just a
real-life that be amazing like take ten
years off my face but that means you
could [ __ ] sequel eyes things and
shoot scenes cost you a lot of money
because that procedure ain't cheap right
but you can young people up man we've
seen young on Schwarzenegger in like
three Terminator movies at this point
excellent points and the fact that he's
also 73 years old and the text only
getting better so like soon know have
him looking like an 18 year old [ __ ]
longer young Schwarzenegger
there's four two younger so Blade Runner
electric boogaloos is being made not
official title not official title but
totally should be yeah I believe that's
what the philip k dick original was
coming Electric Sheep : electric meter
team of electric might have gotten there
was one more draft its own writing
he was also high stuff but but Jared
Leto Leto the Joker damn that well
that's the Cesar Romero Joker music I
don't know what the current Jared Leto
Joker music would be I guess it would be
a thirty seconds from our song
I saw him on the red carpet for as soon
as I squatted you mirror did say he did
actually we were walking into the party
goes hey man is a hey great job dude you
guys you liked it and I said yeah I
really did I liked and I start talking
specifically what I liked and I think he
kind of lost interested boys okay
somebody marches like I have to go kill
a rat to drop on somebody else's death
he was getting out of there before I was
like did you really do those things but
anyway seemed like a nice guy when I
talked to him he is now gonna be in
blame I'm sure he's gonna be play
running to roll yet to be determined
specified but he's in the film that is a
pretty [ __ ] man like my God he's
[ __ ] stunning to look at really
good-looking dude so he's got to be a
replicant right he looks like he could
play Sean Young's kid who you know knows
I mean I'm sure they're not doing at
Rachel's kid but she he got has the same
look to him I think that she did Sean
young that was her name that is her name
that is her name she's still around yeah
she's still there was that line from
Fight Club does she come back I don't
know all things really yeah I don't
think so
come on man what's third excuse like
other up when she's replicant she died
I think the excuses we don't want young
young in this [ __ ] this is not called
Blade Runner to call home coming laborer
to Harrison Ford's back [ __ ] everyone
else second we got almost but they got
rid of this guy they got rid this guy so
I need everybody wins alright so the
Joker's got Jared Lowe has got a post
Joker job he's
some people were wondering what was
gonna happen after like really get hired
again yes look like that you get hired
again yeah no doubt also when you have
an Oscar you get hired again he does
have Tim he does not experience - you
talk about Jordan Catalano [ __ ]
I mean my so-called life Mira Sorvino is
got Tim oh yeah haven't seen her in a
while
that's oh is that your point I was like
well let's just talk about her hey
that's right she got ten well I always
look at it as like she got hurt in she
dropped the mic she's like [ __ ] it
yeah I got sucked in what's she been up
to I think she happily married and
should probably I'm sure she living in
wonderful life she's like I got an Oscar
well you got to either of you ever ask
were like no mr. B no she's not gonna
shut the [ __ ] up I got one she's like
now I got to turn my back on you yeah
man she [ __ ] goes back to the
barbecue it's good for the best dad but
I got from the that's true that's close
enough I got my Boulevard if an alien
from space saw you getting yours on
Hollywood Boulevard and the people
dressed up at the the [ __ ] Oscar place
getting there would they make a
difference of course not these are
things get awards and give them to each
other just for walking Abel into a gift
shop America Michael Pena yeah is next
in the casting news another name that we
all love from ant-man I've seen so many
of those little memes online where they
write like all I want for infinity war
is a is now what is it all I want
infinity war is a recap of civil war by
this guy and it's Michael panniers
character the one it was like so my
cousins this guy Federico he told me
this guy is electric in that movie um
anyway he's as we all suspected and
hoped and why would they go forward
without him Michael Pena is back in
ant-man and the wasp that's what the
movies called yeah there you go ant-man
in this and the wasp the sting of the
wasp would call it [ __ ] that it ain't
right
even plays that's good news man like
forgive I went to see him Alan Watson he
wasn't there I'd be like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
it I'm not watching well keep watching
just so I'm not gonna love it but I was
in [ __ ] all right you got me marble but
I'm glad that he's back he was awesome
in that movie fantastic and I look
forward to Payton redirecting that pain
redirecting I'll see any movie Peyton
Reed directs Ben I he I liked down with
love and I like the bring it on and a
lot he's always I think he's really good
that I do he's gonna do he seems like a
good time to admit that at San Diego
like at a party just chilling do tell do
tell yeah we were standing by some pool
as every party in San Diego his move
he'd push it was a guy look what I did
to this loser everybody his like I
didn't know Peyton Reed was that guy but
apparently is a pool pusher full pushing
Peyton but yeah like we just hung out
for like 15-20 minutes and just talked
about [ __ ] I didn't know he was until
like halfway there come Cisco yeah oh
you're like I thought you were Peyton
Manning it's your film makers don't stop
creating nice guys super nice guy super
nice hair super chill was that a party
he did not need to be at and was talking
to be bleeding no need to talk to it
seems like a lamb to a party on a
Saturday night
the do rock did get laid got in a fight
uh-huh ain't no big thing he was doing a
little [ __ ] kiss MIT what know what
to do wrong I'm wrong to do my mom
button together you couldn't medley and
that's when you're separated
conversation was done at that point
yeah just jettison I just polish it you
heard it here first ladies and gentlemen
Peyton Reed good guy breaking news on
fat Matt Bevin did but is directing a
last piece of casting information is
that of the vocal variety plays
gentleman that of the voice where an
actor is disembodied and the only part
of their performance that you see is
what you hear is it oral well put or is
it
oral ooh aur al
yeah this mark shows ringing it [ __ ]
smart learn about comics yes
so anyway and soundwaves they're making
this Batman : return of the caped
crusader
I think Ralph Garman gave him this idea
the guy that doing all of the Babylon we
were working on the Batman 66 book and
he kept telling people is like you guys
need to do this because these cats are
still around Adam West Burt Ward Julie
Newmar he's going you should make an
animated version so they could play
these characters again and they did but
not with Ralph which was unfortunate
because I think honestly you know I'm
sure you hear cases of people coming up
similar ideas but like he was way out
front with this idea if you've been
talking about it for years actually so
it's finally happening and stuff Adam
West the great item was the OG Batman
our generations Batman
that's right though bright Knight as he
calls himself not the Dark Knight he is
doing the voice of Batman again and Burt
Ward young Robin his faithful companion
sidekick whatever yeah yeah the guy with
no pants pantsless Robin he is back Burt
Ward's Noah and Julie Newmar played
Catwoman is playing Catwoman this I love
this I support this one thousand ten
thousand percent you know why hey it's
good it's meaningful it's sentimental to
me and I like all these people involved
and I like Batman 66 but most
importantly means when I'm like 70 75
there may be a straight-to-video [ __ ]
Jay and Silent Bob cartoon that I can do
the voice of the song above you
absolutely good and that'll be the
easiest money I'll let her select he
sounds older yeah like he don't say
anything he's Silent Bob get miss
[ __ ] check give us money Jay where's
my muscle listen could you do your
silence but a younger man silence yeah
can we get another take of that I'm like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me I can't even
have a bowel movement you want me to say
the [ __ ] twice I'm 78 I'm never gonna
live to be seventy eight but I dream
about it
success science science science yeah
and science science we were eighties
kids
I'm good also what they're going to
discover that there is some kind of
preservative quality and we
[ __ ] I east in all of this
cannabis awesomeness pickle the THC C
just living forever everywhere
not over my gums um yeah man why not
right cuz then maybe I can [ __ ] I can
stick around for my own animated movie
mm-hmm
I would love it if they did Batman call
and return of the Caped Crusader's :
meets J and son but remember how like
[ __ ] scooby-doo met totally Batman
Batman and Robin I would like to meet
Batman and Robin like the Hong
Globetrotters would meet everybody
yes yes I would like Batman : which
other key appreciators : ha
Globetrotters : South James how about oh
my god this is why our friends David
Ross that's such a good idea I support
that Harlem Globetrotters would it be
Meadowlark and curly well I mean I know
they're exist they still exist go out
and see the harm Globetrotters whenever
they're in your hometown but with all
due respect if I'm gonna do a cartoon
movie and it's about min 66 then I want
metal arc and curly clearly they can't
do their own voices but somebody may be
like there's a descendant or something
like that we just fill them are to do
their voices excellent pole instead of
giving it to a family member we steal
back to an actor but he's so good he's
voice of Green Lantern I know he's oh
he's also the voice of the clerks
cartoon he's a guy that says in the
baseball episode there's a you know the
Dante's that sees Jay and saw Bob saw
Bob like throws balls Jay throws the
ball and he goes who is that kid he's
like that's that's you know Jay and
whatever he goes he's in the he's in the
8th grade or something like that
Dante's like he's in eighth grade
because he got left back oh ha that's
for the great Philemon right there also
Marvin who gets shot in the face in Pulp
Fiction that is that's right now I think
he was in meat this season was it I
think so I want to say he's also the
subway scene in spider-man 2
in the Train yeah which I watched last
night anybody above the ground yeah they
both yell when they're when Doc Ock
inspired minified he's inside that train
he's like the Forrest Gump of the ship
you know always find him everywhere pops
up he's a Leroy gone not to be confused
with bad bad Leroy Gump no baddest Gump
in the whole damn zone we're done
amusing ourselves gentlemen that is all
the casting news that's fit to print or
at least talk about I'm sure something
else will happen between now and then
then we'll feel like me where does it
behind the time some people like why
didn't you talk about this this was only
the biggest news in comics ever well
that's just because we wrapped this
episode man tape this [ __ ] in the past
you see it in the future our future your
present deal with that soldiers sound of
metal and cool mark made it up yes
chrono knots jump on board as we speed
through time fixing the time stream
there's a moot there's a TV show
timeless I think it's called
yeah so bored for it and it literally
[ __ ] the tag line I was like well
that's just legends of tomorrow it's the
same thing it's like they must go
through time and fix the time stream and
I'm like well I'm watching that show
already yeah
and it also has a be the future or what
if something like that but without
superheroes I'm like I'm out guess we
don't have any superheroes we're NBC
Universal but then know it but we got
the girl from Mad Men I'm like ooh I
like her I mad and I watch the episode
about we got that do for the off your
light weight when LuAnn visited judge
who Goering isn't it shock I yeah I'm
back in yeah hey you know what they're
making them definitely want to watch
time travel show time a remake TV show
time after time yeah yes time after time
as a movie we saw when we were kids man
it's [ __ ] dope film where HG Welles
the author creates a time machine and
then his friend who we don't know is
Jack the Ripper jumps into that time
machine and jumps into the [ __ ]
future the 70s in the
70s are present now the past distant
past but they I think it might've been
the ages to be fair I think we got to
like 80 or 81 that was this guy maybe at
the tail end of it yeah because that was
whole thing was a Jack the Ripper could
navigate the disco bars of New York and
why cuz he cause he was always with
prostitutes there like prostitution is
just like Cisco loose women and ill
morals and cocaine but we're not selling
the movie very well but he G Wells takes
upon himself to jump back into the time
sheet to get in time she'd travel the
future to stop Jack the Ripper that's
the whole [ __ ] show well that was the
movie and he meets Mary Steenburgen who
runs the museum or something like that
which works at the back at the side
Historical Society and then she falls in
love and should honking McDowell is
playing HG Wells he's fantastic David
Warner plays [ __ ] and Jack the Ripper
man oh it's a good movie so they're
turning into a TV show and Genesis
Rodriguez who's in Tuscon yoga hosers
yoga hosers in theaters September 2nd or
an August 30th in fathom event screen
she's in she's in and I think she's
playing the Mary Steenburgen oh right
okay you know what they should make a TV
show out of what I'll tell you I'll give
it away for free because I don't know it
don't have any stake in it done
Time Bandits well you're gonna say
buckaroo banzai was gonna say they're
working on that right now
Amazon who who's working on it time ban
is a good idea because you can episodic
that all the time Spears like every
episode is a new thing all you need is
little people and all you need is little
people and that kid he gets to grow up
on camera they only had to do the one
movie so the kid was the same age all
the time right but I would watch the
[ __ ] I don't make time man is TV me too
I like that movie so there's my that's
belongs to you go do a thing Terry
Gilliam and get him as an exec producer
man yeah good make it happen
there it is it's a bunch of cast in
newsweek Lunken we gave you a goddamn no
that's not how we on the show we on the
show like this
for Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin come on
thanks for hanging out let's come back
again next time same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast come for
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith he's right
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder